what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we're getting into thort well
it's technically not called for reborn
but it might as well be um it's
basically odin son going back to being
in the role of fork which i mean it's
cool but I like Jane Foster is Thor I
mean III miss Jane Foster restore she
was awesome I mean I don't know if we'll
ever get a character get her going back
to being Thor again but she was awesome
as for and I thought it was great
storytelling but this is Odin son going
back to being the being the character
himself now what's happened here the way
this picks up is is this is out in
Thailand this is actually kind of
interesting because technically speaking
this should be in Korea and I'll explain
why here in a second but this starts off
in Thailand and it actually starts off
with Thor having raided the temple of
sit Iraq to steal something called the
Warlock sigh now the Warlocks eye is a
very very old artifact this goes all the
way back to Thor 131 and that well
technically speaking it's yeah I guess
it's man it's weird journey into mystery
and Thor anyway it goes back to Thor's
the 131 by Stan Lee and Jack Kirby the
warlocks I was an artifact that if a
person used it they could basically
dominate the minds of others now
morville has a lot of artifacts like
that right like like different things
like that Doctor Strange can do that
telepaths can do that that's one of the
things I want you guys to keep in mind
for future reference when it comes to
the Infinity stones they are unique in
their own right in the sense of like
there are only one set of Infinity
stones but there's a lot of other
objects out there that can do something
akin to it or are sometimes equally
dangerous like the casket of ancient
winters the Crimson bands and the
Crimson Jamis interact depending on how
you use them they can actually pretty
damn dangerous but Thor's raided the
temple for the purpose of capturing the
eye and the reason why is because
following the destruction of as Gardea
basically the rebuild as you are that
iron man had made following the events
of siege when man god had stormed the
the gates really of s Gardea and sort of
you know tearing everything up and
basically destroyed the entire area the
weapons of odin hit essentially was like
flung across the cosmos and travel
across the you know to different realms
that are not really realms where
different places across really the main
Marvel Universe proper now there is an
indication here it has trouble to cross
the realms but Thor can't see into those
and we'll find out why here in a second
but the Warlocks eye is one of these
objects now the warlocks I remember
correctly was taken it was it was
discovered and then used against Odin
unsuccessfully and then Odin took it and
kept it inside the in comes inside
Asgard that's the way things worked back
then it's one of the reasons why if you
go watch like the first Thor movie or
Thor 2 you'll see that Odin has
like all these weapons gathered around
his room those are weapons that he
gained over the years by defeating
various foes it's not things have just
always existed in inside of inside of
Asgard but with regards to the arrival
or I guess regards to the the temple
itself and why it should be in Korea the
reason for this is is twofold the first
is that because of the fact that Thor
had raided the temple he cannibals the
the servants of CID Iraq in turn callin
their champion who's a newly reformed
juggernaut the other reason for this is
because during the original act essence
which is to say the various demons of
other dimensions gathering together to
see who was the strongest the crimson
gem as it was created by CID Iraq and
left on earth for some future person to
find and become the juggernaut that
happened in Korea it didn't happen in
Thailand so it's kind of an interesting
thing now we can largely assume that
like different temples were made over
the years and we can sort of jump to
that assumption but the way it was
originally done the way it was covered
in eighth day juggernaut there was only
ever just one temple of CID Iraq there
weren't multiple temples but when you
have juggernaut showing up here we end
up finding out that when Kane Marco went
back to being the servant of sin Iraq
that he's more powerful now than he's
ever been before now a lot of that was
because when Cain Marko originally
gained the game the the crimson gem that
it was just a fraction of sinner acts
powers and those powers that the potency
would wax and wane over the years of
course the most of the most notable
example the strongest juggernauts ever
been was try on juggernaut but aside
from that this is basically him more in
tune with sin Iraq being granted more
power due to the fact that presumably
Sid Arak realized juggernaut could leave
at any point in time
instantly didn't want him to and so you
end up having Thor who's basically given
a hammer by by by one of the drawers and
then shows up and then goes to smash it
on juggernaut and it doesn't work the
hammer goes to pieces remember Mjolnir
is was thrown into the Sun by Jane
Foster so as far as Jason Aaron's
telling us it's basically lost now a
Wolpe Thor will discovered eventually I
mean it's the nature of comics
everything that changes goes back to
being the same again but this hammer
doesn't work it has kind of fractures on
on juggernaut and so in turn where
juggernaut starts to like help Thor Thor
in turn calls back out to to the to the
dwarves again and says give me more
hammers and they just bring like
thousands of hammers crashing down onto
earth so it's literally Thor fighting a
juggernaut
with thousands of hammers and we don't
initially see it all happen in fact we
don't we only see them pick up like one
of the hammers and then use that hammer
to like crushed running out across the
face and then you just skip to the next
scene which is kind of disappointing
because I would kind of want to see Thor
fight juggernaut with
thousand hammers because like when he
gets there when he takes the eye and he
gets back to the divorce he ends up
telling him yeah I had to use them all
like I had to use all the hammers and so
they've all been destroyed
I need more which is kind of funny but
it's a little bit sad cuz again like I
would kind of wanted to see that I know
you guys do nobody ever watches Thor to
see him talk people people like they
read Thor comics like they want to see
if Thor's like smash and stuff is it The
Incredible Hulk
people just like yeah I want to see The
Incredible Hulk smash things I know how
you guys are cuz I'm the same way I'm
the exact same way but uh but the fact
remains that we end up having him
basically travel to visit directly
without with Odin and when he's talking
to Odin Odin actually asked about her
and of course this is own referring to
Jane Foster and this has been a change
for his character and his name is
interesting because Jane Foster had
earned the respect of Odin at the end of
the story arc because when all the
Asgardians failed and in the moment of
testing when Odin was basically faced
with man god the one being in the entire
Marvel Universe hit Odin is actually
scared of Jane Foster was the only one
to stand up and rise to the challenge
and so she basically she picked up the
slack where Odin was weak and that
really earned some some brownie points
and earn some respect from Odin so
that's when he asked the question do you
know where she is because Odin is
actually concerned about Jane Foster
which is a total change because Odin was
a reflection of a portion of the fan
base who were just like no Jane Foster
does not need to be thought he was
written to kind of be that way or at
least that seems to have been the case
and so now he's just kind of like yeah
like like what happened to her but then
you end up having Thor transition back
to Midgard and in the Bronx no less and
meet up with meet up with Jane Foster
only for us to find out that again the
war of Wilms is still going on so
Malekith the accursed this warlord of
the Dark Elves is still like running
across all the various realms and
destroying everything that he can find
and literally just like like just laying
siege to everything they just just
annihilating everything that he can find
that's really all he's doing and so we
end up finding out that that like a lot
of these refugees these various elves
and dwarves and so on and so forth who
have fled from their realms are being
given safe passage in in the Bronx and
not only that Jane Foster is actually
recovering from her cancer so it's
really basically Jason Erin's way of
saying she's not gone yet which I'm very
excited about that makes me very very
happy I'm very pleased to see that but
it's really kind of the aftermath of Adz
guards destruction you have like like
for example Heimdall lost his eyes so we
can't see everything he could not see
into the into the other realms and see
how the realms are faring the Bifrost
bridge is broken so Thor can't go there
as guards basically cut off
from everywhere except for Midgard that
that's really the only place he can get
to and so we really have Jane Foster
essentially tell for that the next
weapon he's looking for is something
called the gem of infinite Suns and for
the most part it's exactly what it
sounds like it's a gem that houses the
power of a thousand stars the reason why
it matters is if you go back and you
read the old stories the old four
stories there was a point where he was
attacked with the casket of ancient
winters which creates like infinite cold
and the Jim of infinite suns countered
that it's basically the yin and the yang
to the to the casket of ancient winters
it kind of exists you know as yin and
yang to each other but tracking that
down again it's just another weapon that
was lost from from Asgard which Thor is
trying to locate now for the most part
it initially seems like busywork right
it just kind of seems like well Thor's
just kind of here doing things and
tracking down weapons and so on and so
forth and it doesn't really seem like he
serves a purpose but this changes when
Loki shows up here we basically find out
that Thor has been taking all these
weapons in like throwing him to a
singular location and well really on a
boat and which is kind of cool to see
Thor like partying on a yacht but still
location up here I like the way the
Jason Aaron does this because Thor is
immediately hostile to him
right because he's like hey look you
stabbed free in the back of the
beginning of this whole thing the start
of the war of realms and it was a
poisoned dagger and Frey was unconscious
and almost dead for quite some time but
again the way that Jason Aaron has done
this he's been riding Loki in such a way
to where it seems like there's actually
something else going on and Jason here
has been tight-lipped about it like we
have no idea it's just there's something
else happening here aside from Loki just
turning against Freya and joining
Malekith in the war of realms we don't
know exactly what it is but it seems
like he's not entirely evil anymore and
so when he Williams are basically
telling Thor he essentially tells him
look you're gonna have to go on a
journey here and this journey you're
gonna go on is going to locate one of
the weapons you're looking for but it's
the weapon that will win the war and so
it's kind of cool because that entices
Thor to a degree enough for him to kind
of stop in and ask the question what are
we talking about and Loki says will you
have to go on a journey and find out and
opens a portal and since the war off to
another location but the funny thing
about this is Thor is just like nope I'm
not going alone and grabs Loki and drags
him in look he's just like what are you
doing man like like you're gonna mess up
the spell so it's kind of a funny moment
between two brothers but we end up
finding out that that where Loki has
taken Thor to is essentially the realm
of health but it's kind of crazy because
when this happens you end up having
hella who shows up here and says if you
want to survive this place you need to
come with me and the implication here is
that hella has lost control of her own
realm it is a pretty cool scenario I
mean we do know what happens
there's also a few more issues you know
to get us caught up but it is a cool
scenario because it's basically like
Hellas lost control of her own realm or
at least that seems to be the case and
basically she's there alongside Loki and
Thor to really figure out like how in
the heck to survive this whole thing so
it's kind of cool and it's actually
pretty interesting and I'm curious to
see what direction it goes in but yet
another part in this war of runs that's
why I keep telling you guys when Jason
Aaron finishes his run on Thor when he
finally sits down the pan and says we
are now done it's gonna be probably the
greatest run of Thor ever written I mean
starting with the old like Thor god of
thunder with with God butcher running
all the way up because it goes that far
back running all the way up until now
it'll be one of the greatest runs of his
character that was like ever told it's
actually pretty pretty spectacular well
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
- comments explained make sure you guys
at the sub button to become part of the
Rob core if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]
you